you think you know everything about
breath of the wild well we've got even
more secrets for you if you continue to
follow this series and want us to keep
making more just hit that like button
alright here we go
players have seen this ball and chain
mechanism with some korok puzzles hidden
around Hyrule but did you know that this
chain can actually snap in half
weird part about this is this only
happens when enough force is put on the
chain and the chain doesn't simply
disappear immediately it actually does
SNAP in half until it touches Solid
Ground at least then the connecting
chain will disappear fully when
something is cooked or frozen they
actually have different skin properties
shooting a normal or ancient Arrow into
a piece of raw or cooked meat will
puncture it as you think it should
but if it's frozen solid it'll actually
bounce off because of the frozen solid
skin
here are some Advanced combat 101 for
you when you shoot at a choo choo jelly
there's a couple tricks for combat that
could be useful pertaining to shock
damage shooting shock arrows at jellies
normally doesn't do anything but a basic
trick is to stay sister choo choo jelly
first then shoot it with shock arrows to
do area of effects damage
[Music]
but that's not the only way to trigger
this if the choo choo jelly switches
elements during bullet Time by shooting
next to it there's about a second or so
that it can't be destroyed so again with
the shot girl you can use this to
conduct electricity but even further
players have even combined this neat
trick with an old combat technique
called SJC or Shield jump cancel to get
bullet time and drop materials at the
same time for players who haven't dived
into advanced combat Shield jump cancels
have led to players finding some really
neat combinations such as shooting a
spicy Pepper or sun trim with a fire
arrow to updraft right out of an SJC
or the fanciest of them all throw a
boomerang SJC and drop a flint and
pepper together to have the boomerang
hit the Flint light the pepper and send
you a Sky High
if you want to learn about this trick
there's a bookmark to my combat glossary
in the description below there's a
common interaction between wandering
Travelers and Link went up against
enemies after the shuffle the NPCs will
give link a small reward depending on
how tough the enemy was but this is
based on three levels easy medium and
hard enemies thing is the dramatic hard
interactions are very very rare if not
impossible for most NPCs in normal
gameplay because they design these
traveling NPCs to follow roads that
almost never cross paths with gold and
silver enemies so the only way to get
these messages is to glitch or kite
these enemies on purpose along with you
and force them to fight them near NPCs
then you can finally see these rare
conversations that probably very few
players have ever seen
there's tons of missable mini
interactions if you pay close attention
in every town including hatano Village
such as the kids following you with a
blue flame and a flock of sheep taking
shelter under the tree at night or
during rain you can also get another
limited interaction with the kids
staring at poora's lab where if you get
in their line of sight they actually
tell you to move out of the way and even
get physically upset if you move in
front of them Kula the korok and korok
Forest asks for specific wands during a
side quest but did you know that the
reward will change depending on which
Rod is brought such as the weaker ice
rod to the stronger blizzard Rod which
will reward 100 rupees or 300 rupees
instead
[Music]
through the compendium players can
collect pictures of Many Items including
equipment enemies flora and fauna these
of course can then be used to track
specific things around Hyrule one of
them used to be this yup very early in
development koroks were supposedly
trackable through the sheikah Slate this
compendium image of a korok was listed
as NPC hidden korok ground and The Mask
textures were still missing entirely but
later in development they must have
switched this idea to have the korok
masks specifically have this ability
instead if you're a collector in breath
of the wild chances are you've run into
an annoying problem there's a limit on
how many armor pieces you can hold with
107 total pieces of armor in the game
with DLC and duplicates that you could
easily get the 100 armor limit may be a
nuisance but there are some interesting
interactions that come with this unique
situation when trying to get additional
armor especially through story beats
such as la flat telling you your pouch
is too full for the Zora Greaves keema
saying is truly not trying to cheat you
out of a deal for the Fireproof here and
bozai thinking your bag is too full of
cute boots to hold any more items a
second side effect of this is with
Villia specifically during the cutscene
where link Dawns the disguise for the
first time link wears this outfit but if
you hit the armor limit the disguise
won't fit in your bag and you'll just
come out wearing whatever you had on
[Music]
whoa adorable stamina usage changes
depending on how harsh the angle of the
inclines and declines you're climbing on
but did you know that you have an
outright stem and a penalty when
climbing in the rain besides the obvious
slipping it actually takes more stamina
to climb while it's raining but not only
that there's a developer oversight with
this because in some situations while
it's raining but you're in a covered
area you'll still get the stamina
penalty meaning in situations like this
with chica Towers will take more stamina
to climb even though it's technically a
dry surface whoops the Zora Rito Goron
and garudo of course have special
weapons tied specifically to their race
but Nintendo's development for these
weapons had a ton of forethought put
into their designs such as gorons who
have two-handed weapons but not
one-handed because all of their
two-handed weapons are used as
one-handed weapons because of their
large stature so a single-handed weapon
would be way too small and they don't
use Shields because well they're gorons
Rito on the other hand are the opposite
they don't don't have two-handed weapons
because of the heavy weight needed to
carry around that kind of weapon while
flying even their weapons they already
have are lightweight such as the kite
shield made out of cloth or feathered
weapons but with inset holes to reduce
the weapon's weight the Gerudo focus on
their Shields with aptitude for shield
surfing and the Zora loved their Spears
making all of their equipment out of
silver which pure silver never rusts
perfect for an aquatic environment you
know each race focuses on these
equipment specifically because for their
preferred equipment it always comes in a
set of three we explained before how
Nintendo previously planned to use Ruby
Sapphires and topaz to craft your own
Elemental Arrow recipes while that
didn't make it into the game Elemental
Stone usage is in the game just through
lore instead each Elemental circlet has
a respective element equipped into the
metal but not only that every Elemental
weapon has an element infused stone at
the bottom of the blade otherwise known
as the weapons pommel these holder
rubies Sapphires and topazes in place to
power the Elemental properties of the
weapon during development one of the
best ways they tackle the production
issues and ideas was through a system
that let their staff leave physical
comments in game for developers to see
and fix this system they designed was
called Zelda error which made it quick
and easy to drop a comment whenever they
ran into an issue and was even doable
while the game was running live which
made the debugging process hassle free
according to Takoma oisa QA engineer and
programmer at Nintendo this was the
first ever Zelda in the series to
implement this system and with how
polished this game came out in the end I
won't be surprised if they use this
ingenious QA system again
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below we of course still have an ongoing
playlist with all the latest breath of
the wild content still coming so keep it
here on Gamespot
foreign